Let's talk about whitespace for a moment. So, you may have
noticed when I was entering text in the, in the editor
before, that even though I put text on multiple lines, when
I rendered it in HTML it rendered all on a single
line. This is because in HTML all whitespace, new lines, tabs,
spaces all turn into a single space. To force our HTML
to have multiple lines we can use another tag called the
br tag. It looks like this. It is also a void tag,
stands for break, and it's a void tag. And
you put this after, after any lines that you want to
appear on multiple lines. Let's let's play around with
this in the browser a little bit. Here we are
in the browser. Let's let's enter some text. We've
got this text that's really too long for one line,
and when we render this, it appears as one line.
Let's put a line break here. When I render this,
it still appears as one line. If we
want to render multiple lines, we can enter the br
tag like here. No problem. And now we have a line break. And we can even enter
multiple br tags if we want multiple line
breaks. 'Kay? There we go. Two line breaks or
two br's equals two line breaks. Cool, huh? Another
way of doing line breaks is to use the
p tag. This stands for paragraph. This is not a,
a void tag. So the p tag has content and
it looks like this. So it's, that you know, because
it's not a void tag, it has a closing tag, and
we have a opening tag. So you've got opening p,
content, closing p, and this will render as one paragraph.
let's check this out in the browser really quick Okay.
So we've got these two lines. Let's take a different approach.
I'm going to start this line with a paragraph tag,
and we'll, we'll render this. Ah-ha. Now we've got a
line break here in our text. Now the font got
bigger, and that's kind of a side effect of our,
of our HTML tool. It must be some sort of
style set on p. That doesn't normally happen. I'm going to
wrap the, the bottom line with a paragraph as well.
Okay. There we go. Now we've got two lines the
same kind of basic idea as we had before.
Now, we'll, we'll talk about why there's this extra space
in here even though there's no space between this
text up here. We'll come to that in a minute.
But first, quiz time. Take this text here. Hello,
everyone, we're using two lines now. And enter the HTML
to draw that as it's formatted here, with two lines.
And I want you to use the, the br tag.